what was it like the first time you saw
yourself
as ariel i know there's probably like
some test situations but like the moment
that you recognize yourself as oh my
gosh that's her
what went through your mind super
special i mean today is really exciting
because it's the first time i've seen
the trailer i've seen it today
and that little extra special something
they showed i was like wow
so it's all exciting and surreal i'm
seeing it all come together
[Music]
this is the first time you saw yourself
saying a part of your world yeah wow how
are you feeling i went in the trailer
and bawled my eyes out and now i'm here
so i'm just like this is really weird if
they have an out-of-body experience
right now
i'm sure it is i mean
could you have imagined coming to this
point i mean like are you getting the
role is phenomenal working on it i'm
sure there's a lot of pressure and you
want to do a good job but now that
you've done your part
what's your impression of how it's all
coming together seeing you're seeing
yourself sing the song and watching the
trailer
does it feel like yeah this is real now
yes it definitely feels real now i mean
we finished filming about a year and a
half ago
so i've kind of been just living my
whole normal life and not really
thinking about it and then all of a
sudden today seeing it i'm like wow this
is real it wasn't a dream
yeah do you feel like it came to it came
together the way that you thought it
would come together absolutely
absolutely it's blown away my
expectations like
by far and what did it mean for you to
like after they played this clip of you
singing the song you came out and
thunderous applause in that room that
must feel really nice yeah i'm just so
grateful i'm like wow they're clapping
it's cool i mean really though wow
they're like of course they're clapping
was there ever really was there ever
really a question in your mind that
that like i don't know if this is gonna
work out the way i wanted it to you know
i think as you analyze yourself as a
person you always have those doubts and
they're like well i hope people like my
version of it and just kind of give it
to god and see what happens you know but
seeing everyone's reaction over
something that's so special and near and
dear to my heart is so nice and kind and
i know that i put my all into it so i
know that i'm proud of myself at the end
of the day did you send the trailer to
the family have they watched it just
blowing my phone up it's like
yeah what your sister said my sister is
like non-stop texting me right now
so i can't wait to get back to them